her about we'll stop making transformer
movies when you stop watching them so he
tells his friends long powerful than the
pounding surf pounding surfing his pet
name for Aquaman my handling hurricane
or what Chicagoans call Tuesday the Man
of Steel
Clark 10 I mean I'm in real trouble
remarkable physical strength Superman
fights a never-ending battle for truth
and justice disguised as a mild-mannered
newspaper reporter Clark Kent
not very well disguised but come on for
an alien from another world
pretty good Superman
fighting creaking frog chirping crickets
and Muppets who talk backwards to teach
you the Horten
because the murderer dating from the
Addams Family their Friday night for a
young Norman Bates plush this cartoon is
about the flash sorry for the Superman
credits the new Justice League movie is
throwing us off of it the city it's been
identified as a watch 1 at the
metropolis munitions plant there's a
story or I'm no reporter there might be
a story at the plant Lois Lois me name
is Lois not Lois thief why is everybody
in tights me name wrong what is
happening right now
Lois uh-huh Louise Lucy now I'm so mixed
up I don't know who I am
your perving the creeps facing you
belong in a Ralph Bakshi film this is
Philadelphia's idea of going
[Music]
okay Watchmen take your post in the main
shop and be on the alert yes sir thank
you sir oh pardon me the threatening old
guy standing at door music yeah at the
BC factory people are friend to figure
out why Lego Batman is the best Batman
movie in years Seren done labeling she
Hawks vibrator now what do I do
[Music]
what upstairs 12 o'clock very important
um who are you
what hap Stan's twelve o'clock very
important my lips are finally going to
fly off my face I want you to see this
whole Factory is responsible for
building Bill Maher's money I know what
the place shot was ooh
[Music]
this looks like a job for a useless pawn
that was a good job you did on the
watchman last night Zack Snyder knows
how to destroy a good superhero movie
what can you do with Superman - the
switch on a plant flow below what then
the watchman is some good snooping there
Louis yeah it would be proud it's okay
on fake news get that 50 year-old
midlife crisis having girl Jesus
spider-gwen in heels couldn't move like
that you will join the cult of physic
filling oh yeah took me allowed to see
you there
[Music]
okay look I'm an airplane yeah don't
look up my skirt
[Music]
hey they're putting you in torpedoes 777
that's pretty lucky all right man now
load em a dynamite
well that security guard got huge
[Music]
yeah that's what happens when you get
your guards from the Sunny Acres
retirement all just another day for the
evil blind polar Jones speaking hello
Jones we're ready for the test send up a
torpedo immediately immediately was that
really warm usek the green tractor
helping develop weapons of mass
destruction for 80
here comes the torpedo now isn't it
exciting because experimental purposes
there is no explosive in the torpedo
there is a reporter named Lois Lane but
I never liked her columns in a bizarre
twist that pervy guy named Lois from
earlier saves the day ah did you forget
to show us he's a super mystic fire I
get me finally fed up with her well
blows me down something's gonna lose me
up
[Music]
[Applause]
how did he see her when he came and
opened his eyes
Lane miss lane
are you alright
[Music]
they're about to blow up the plant and
I'm southern now for some reason most
people make a bubble gum popping sound
when punched by the Man of Steel oh
[Music]
alright I'll escape in this and nobody
will ever if I was not what I wanted he
looked out on the passenger side that
confuses me now watch as he spells
Frances with him
time for me to pick up this truck and
drop it off in a safe way or I could do
this too seems a bit more complicated
I immediately regret this again feel
like we missed the scenes well pop
Superman put an end to their little egg
and this was immense yours large yeah
you're really good at seeing through
disguises love
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
along and remember so you don't have no
resource reshoot process we need to redo
the review authority do you see the
Department of cameos review one with the
pop song you mean the one I was told to
do like another comic book trailer that
may or may not have a talking raccoon in
it we can't confirm no to that and we
need to add more comedy
you're changing halfway just because a
competitor is doing better well DC is
usually a few months behind
yes ah okay we need programs doing what
cutting out what they like the most
videos GOP on this sucker right goes
without saying well I wouldn't do that
why not
yeah Jin's been playing Joker offset
like Jared Leto did on the movie oh by
the way here you go
yes he mails the shit like Leto too
because the real Joker would do that
oh look anal be real master of crime how
much does even funny the children
supposed to be funny yeah
who's there you're holding anal beach
since accruals are falling out well my
man of a surprise you sure they aren't
just plastic tears I met amazing private
gym which human sounds a handsome guy
choker jared leto clang joker here
listen we appreciate that you're trying
to create brothers but that's what the
Joker brother people and blow up
buildings yeah that's like dangerous I'd
rather just pretend oh just like a real
Joker yeah so while you're pretending to
do that other stuff why don't you also
pretend that you're doing this second
grader discovering what it's foolish did
well I wouldn't be able to act like an
asshole for no reason oh just like the
real Church little time I'm deeper than
I thought which I can also save those
anal cutting oh you can count them out
all your watch degrees so we're also
going to have to redo the opening
credits Oh
sorry we like Brighton dia
all right let's it's getting me hiked up
I'm ready for action
negative our church show that some
people preferred when you sit at a desk
and do nothing
come on who'd wanna start Suicide Squad
with someone just sitting down for 20
minutes just talking about the main
characters Suicide Squad with someone
sitting down for 20 minutes just talking
about the main characters her name is
Amanda played by Viola Davis
she's an intelligence officer with an
idea so insane and a creepy enough not
to work what do we call what a next
Superman comes to take us out
Wonder Woman no the flesh no Aquaman
no sidewalk no no Lego better hold on
I'll do it those heroes fought even
though that arguably save hundreds a lot
that's not what happens they actually
hear her out if another person is strong
as Superman comes we have to be ready
are you seriously telling me that
supervillains will do less harm than
Superman did you forget how good
metropolis looked after Superman saved
it from that okay yeah our first mug
shot is dead shot then there's assassin
around and possible Savior was enough to
it it also turns out he has a daughter
who knows how to a peacekeeper when he
pisses off the wrong people
it's over Deadpool dad shot oh well this
movie got a lot less cool yeah well
that's never stopped me before
no move out of the way kid I'm gonna
shoot your daddy you oh sorry
usually when people are angry about a
costume man killing people it's about me
[Music]
what I wanted to kill him it's pretty
much walk stated for me to turtle 440
with the Rhino a superpower you get it
Scoob you're going to take down the next
Superman with a boomerang I didn't it
does not business amazingly well she'll
be distracted when I tell you that the
flashes in this movie what is that
disgusting reptilian Beast
after reasonable gonna have to call us
Academy Award Mike suicides why our
makeup or Star Trek build some reason
scary Warner himself the clock
next we will hook a great fire and it's
worn off father but we're saving is
backstory for later the worlds are
skipping for now Harley Quinn little the
story
fanservice we got the Harlequins ill she
was applying for the clown himself he
got us out of mind and made her
dangerous killers okay are you reading
her criminal record over trading card
[Music]
what does your criminal records say
about how she can help us um she has a
mouth okay like okay last one The
Enchantress a young doctor went
exploring in a cave and got possessed by
an evil witch she wants to take over the
world and may have the power reducer
under often Sheol though she's the most
powerful thing online
and that's all you need
what mutation that's all you need you
can just the rest of that binder into
the garbage hey I worked hard to find
the worst of the worst and you came
across boomerang mallet gun a petting
zoo and a guy who makes fire who no
longer makes fire this is all you need
over tension to be on her she's right we
don't need to worry about them as long
as we have that winter control yeah what
do you got her under a lockdown or
military surveillance better we have one
guy looking after her in a hotel room
not enough moron I'm going to see you
it's okay I can call the prove it
oh hi colonel Amanda here
I was just wondering how was that oh
just let me know how that works out
so what appears she's escaped been on
taking over the world will try to rule
the world really means purity cars
played by high pairen holes it's a
surprise isn't it is all time mine
intogen I can't wait to show you my toys
I know you mail me your anal big lessons
who wants to show you my actual scary
toy
we're not gonna see the Marvin no that
seems been cut total this of course but
that doesn't mean that I can't hurt you
pops tree
okay I'll knock it off Jim and let
Walter go but I thought about we said I
need to get more psychotic to get into
character in fact you look under your
desk you might find another president
left for Christ a dead mouse oh yeah
you're really open your Dame but not
just any tecna's doesn't look a little
familiar like a certain you have at home
[Applause]
you can keep it nice look nice yes the
new ship a boy friend said to give you
that oh how sweet
we're in so much trouble
big trouble
what kind of trouble what should have
happened to me
nothing happens he disappears from the
film altogether in fact ah another one
of our brilliant cuts we fizzled that
dizzle for shizzle ma didn't any pay off
what a work hearing no matter how tiny
the choker could lob it home or take
them out while on a run Forsythe's on
the mailing things you could get this in
the mail don't understand critic we're
doing it for the fads yeah you keep
saying that was it use me it means we
don't have to explain that much because
the fans already know like look at this
character on their mission hi I'm katana
and my sword holds the souls of the
enemies that I kill with it
here's equipping me doing something all
they need to know know when you get her
stats and backstories down but we don't
know her what's her personality intrat
dislikes character traits it's not like
say an x-files movie where the
characters are already established in
the TV show this is a different
interpretation that needs to be
established look I know our competitors
may or may not have a talking record
give their characters digital moves then
put them together into what that makes
audiences understand them better and
cheer for them when they come together I
totally forgot where I was going because
they've got the comics Gandalf will be
so much stronger if they replace them
with the Lord of the Rings paperback and
said come on you know this guy right
we're even talking with the idea of
replacing every character in this movie
with recommended issue numbers that way
they can read it on the characters and
we don't even have to write them so
while you may think for the fans means
lazy we like to think it means not that
name one personality trait of Catan no I
don't know I don't recount I'm watching
The Enchantress who also happens to be
in love with her is rape flag disguise
like for the main care during Godzilla
and they so forgettable you probably
don't even realize this isn't for from
Godzilla this is pretty much me switch
that with anyone I'm just going to play
his part are you because the characters
can be introduced with no rhyme or
reason why can't I be one you clicked by
The Enchantress to break out of a man of
control along with her resurrected rug
or the most qualified people in the
world
though he leads his team of villains to
stop the enchantments from taking over
the world and wait a minute how come I
didn't get any bright credits or
backstory Oh what the Native American
guy doesn't get any attention oh no
nothing like that
I'm just here to dye our diet yes it is
you're going to use the remote in that
hand to brought the chip inside my head
and everybody has a chip in their head
okay if you try to escape your diet
around nothing anyone out I think he's
lying give it a shot did you hear that I
try to kill me
discount stop and you're trying to kill
me not just here to die what's my name
dear it hired night after night fool in
creeping red shirt the answer is a
lawyer from Jurassic Park
you know I'm sorry any of you assholes
alright fine I'll dismantle your chip
out of white guilt you happy you know
you're right who does law he was so
inspiring
damn it give me a real Apple stop
telling my text oh why me Lima character
I know it's a risky investment for it
but I thought the sacrifice was worth it
for the character now what are you doing
that's the whole reason why I'm doing
this so I can go to reporters but how
often I get out of here what do you
think about people claiming you're only
doing this for attention they're right
[Applause]
[Music]
so the Suicide Squad make their way
towards the intent thanks to an office
elites discover the Enchantress's
minions
[Music]
I know they're not technically puppies
but they look like them sound like them
and people don't realize how
surprisingly easy they are to kill re
just be a lot shorter if they just shot
people we're not so lucky
alright squad let's fight like we don't
have comfortable carissa fall back on if
this movie doesn't do well wait a minute
I don't think this is dark enough Oh me
like there needs to be more twisted
characters or plot lines no fight why
would you want you to fight scene in the
dark there's people on TV action again
critic the less we give people the more
they can feel and what's good about it
you wouldn't understand critic it's over
there and it will crack the table your
way around it with and then there's
Harley Quinn
Donna is the professor and Miriam as you
can see Harley goes in the elevator
[Music]
hi guys oh well look at her like that
she brought him home
yes that's what she does so we hired her
to do why would we bring her and she
quit my hey my papa
so Diablo isn't fighting but there John
boomerang try to convince it all starts
me oh you don't want me to touch you
some look like Deadshot doesn't realize
it can take years to transform a man
who's worn on fire
you
ah I look like nothing
oh is that really all it took to get you
back into violence
I don't know years of pacifism destroyed
what happened on your head just don't
like people touching my head hey come on
well we appreciate your sacrifice yeah
it's like one of those guys going vegan
for a day I know right pussy about time
you got here
oh right they first had to save Amanda
from being destroyed by the
Enchantress's rap and you would miss
lady hill without them admit Ygritte I
was right see that again I was right
about the Suicide Squad you were right
you were right you're right hitch out
there the one that's destroying the city
I'm sure you're aware her she was part
of a certain team a super team am i
correct name a name for the certain team
if I can hold and that you did it
correct yeah the name of that team again
the one that you gave suicide wait a
minute you were me if I'm wrong beneath
it Green team was ever put together
the one you were right about
you're right like a rocket I'm getting
you off right now humans are you feel
better
yeah I want let's just hope the new
Wonder Woman will be better to save
Harlequin which many die-hard fans of
problem
I think our nation of the two had the
Joker's reading hardly my darkest I mean
to an end he wouldn't a deny to say but
he's the same
once Quinn in terms of Batman war has
not been around very long but her story
is more open to changes in the future
this is an interpretation that's
different but honestly kind of
interesting we've had plenty of times
where the Joker's been self-centered but
it's actually kind of fascinating to see
him honorable and care about an aspect
of the character not often explored so
regardless of which one you like better
I actually don't think it's a bad
version to have up especially because
it's pretty dysfunctional in fact my
back Harley it don't likely I'll be in
the respite picture yeah yeah in the
grand scheme of things I was pretty
pointless greatest Joker who ever Oh
what no they trying to stalkers whoever
the water was played by a douchebag
actor okay remember for something yeah
mr. J is dead I'm a dinosaur but it
looks like the squad was answers from
Rick yours true look Rick Flagg or
whatever your real name is actually that
is supposed to be my real name seriously
okay well we need some answers okay the
most powerful entity in the world has
escaped and now wants to take over the
world
yeah we know we saw that yeah you just
showed it from a slightly different
angle yeah kind of weird repeating that
No the chart says this is where he's
supposed to feel hopeless and get up
what that doesn't seem in character with
any of us yeah every day could be our
last you know no no no no no this is the
part where you have to feel defeated and
push out wait the bad guys are supposed
to push out jiggy now say jiggy
I literally invented jiggy okay let's go
and feel hopeless I guess sure in
feeling hopeless in here it's not like
we're it's life and death every day yeah
I'm crazy so I don't know why I'm here
oh we have a life and Crocket away
[Music]
I'm a dinosaur also Diablos back story
we don't know that thank you my entire
family yeah that's all right
this is the shot me any of you we're bad
god how many times I have to say this
damn movie yeah we should be like she is
not taking over the world
we are taking over the world 15 minutes
in the audience with a guy they pay for
wait you're supposed to give up on a
national speech super villains by
definition are the most motivated people
in the world
I'm not giving to anywhere you've got
the appreciate we are going to defeat
her opening weapon in the guys want to
keep putting it in all these films right
this is some sort of sick erotic dwell
for you she has a sort specific fetish
would no critics it's not that at all
now if you'll excuse me I have some
paperwork to do
oh Avengers Oh Fantastic Four you know
mine all right come on let's go from one
dark shadowy location to another dark
shadowy location boldly go so the squad
get to the enchantress and try to stop
hey hey
you know the whole dancing hula doll you
put on your dance floor
so because it turns out I can do this
what the hell do we know we could turn
into that let me guess for the funding
we wanted that she could give them if
they only join her stop
yeah sure no he's colors
do you see the back signal tantras is
destroyed releasing the doctor inside
and the squad go back to prison upon
treated with little more respect but
there's one more twist let's go home
the character we knew what the live
turns up and naturally quencher ending
but it's the Joker and anything he's in
is immediately amazing not like anything
the Joker done right is amazing here
like everything else in this movie it's
just done passable despite it being a
big hit this movie divided a lot of
audiences some love did some hated it
other thought it was okay honestly
they're all understandable none of it
makes sense and the painting and tone
feels incredibly inconsistent and I
can't imagine why that is what can we
say except you're welcome
when the style and all-around coolness
works I am kind of forgiving up
it's that a lot of dumb boring moments
but the baddest moments are enough for
me the thing I'm glad I thought I know
tell me what audiences are already very
complicated but hearing older you can
hopefully figure out if this is the
right kind of gun for you or the wrong
kind of Dumfries I'm still legitimately
pissed off at the ending just look the
Joker coming in and that's it I'm sorry
should've gone out on a higher note well
you know what this is might become
suicide what and I'm going to pick I'm
going to replace the Joker with the one
character I know we'll get a red
negative reaction
[Music]
[Applause]
you